here are seven simple tips to lower your
monthly bills technically there were ten
i said three of them waste of time cut
them out we're only delivering value
let's go with the top seven here are the
top seven number one
refinance your mortgage i rent i don't
have a mortgage but this is advice
according to go banking rates they said
if you're a homeowner
if you're a homeowner your mortgage is
likely your largest monthly expense your
big three expenses housing
transportation food and beverage housing
is number one your mortgage is your
largest monthly expense so refinance
that thing
i don't know if that's the the verbage
they use i'm using that refinance that
thing
negotiating better terms and a lower
interest rate
to pay off your existing mortgage right
negotiate
better terms and a lower interest rate
to pay off your existing mortgages
call your banker and negotiate that's
number one number two pay down your debt
i always said the best investment
is sometimes not an investment
it's paying off debt yeah there's a lot
of times you're paying
15 20 25
if you're taking out cash advances yeah
so he said get rid of that debt there's
two major strategies to get rid of debt
there's the debt snowball and the debt
avalanche the debt snowball is where you
start with your lowest debt
work your way up bang it out bang it out
bang it out until you finally pay off
your highest debt that avalanche is
basically saying i ain't starting with
the small stuff give me the big stuff
first yeah whatever the highest interest
rate is
all right if it's 400
cash advance whatever it is pay it off
then next highest 25 credit card pay it
off then move on to your car loan maybe
that's eight percent pay it off pay off
the largest interest rate what's hurting
you the most first
and then work your way down so those are
two different methodologies and
strategies you can pay off debt number
three
learn to cook
cook your meals at home here are some
numbers for you the average american
household spends how much you think the
average american household spends
on
eating out
uh what weekly or
uh this is a year or monthly you can do
it what do you think i think i think
monthly it's got to be a
a grand a grand yeah dude i eat out for
lunch almost every day here and it it
really adds up i'll i will i'll give you
some numbers on that here's the numbers
average american household spends 250
bucks a month just eating out which
comes out to three grand a year
okay you're making 30 grand a year 10
right you're making 60 grand that's 5 of
just eating out
all right the average meal at home you
talked about at home versus out average
meal at home four bucks average meal
eating out
13 bucks that's a nine dollar difference
you talked about eating out uh for lunch
every single day yeah let's just let's
do some basic math how much would you
say you spend on lunch every day um
15 to 18 bucks okay so let's just let's
just deliver let's just use easy math
right yeah
ten dollars a day
five times a week that's 2500 bucks a
year now if you're spending
twenty dollars
five times a day five grand a year that
adds
up let me know death by a thousand cops
cancel my death by a thousand tacos bro
four negotiate your bills the cost of
your monthly bills are not set in stone
i repeat these monthly bills are not set
in stone you can negotiate them you can
negotiate them you call up your service
providers and they can get you a
discount here's an example that they
give
if your wi-fi bill
rises after a pro
after a promotional deal expires you can
call up the customer service and say hey
look i'm looking for a cheaper price so
i'm gonna shop around maybe you pull
like a tony soprano look i'm not saying
i'm gonna leave you
i'm just saying that uh maybe
yeah your wi-fi won't be used in my
house anymore let's just say
it won't be found yeah and maybe
you can save a couple bucks that way
anyway negotiate your bills call up call
up negotiate your bills number five for
all my people driving around in cars out
there
shop around for auto insurance
shop around for auto insurance 76 of
people who shopped around for auto
insurance save that money according to a
2021 value penguin survey don't settle
for less if they're saying that three
out of four people actually took the
time to shop around for better rates on
their auto insurance
save that money maybe you want to be one
of those people or maybe you're the one
fourth who's like i'm good i don't want
to save any money yeah those aren't my
people anyway number six cancel unused
unused subscriptions when was the last
time that you actually reviewed your
subscription it's funny you say that
yeah it was actually about maybe a month
ago but before that never yeah i went
through just apple has a nice thing on
your settings where you go through your
icloud and you can just it just shows it
for you and you can just
swipe unsubscribe yeah how do you do
that uh it's you go i think it's on your
icloud you literally go to like general
settings and you type in subscriptions
yep and it pulls up that little sub menu
and it shows you everything you're
subscribed through through apple look at
that look at the value we're
giving to the people at home thank you
david i just had an idea i'm going to be
in an event next next month yeah uh i'm
going to find a sponsor
to the for for these types of uh there's
a there's a company that helps you tally
up your subscriptions there's going to
be some sponsors on this podcast that's
for sure sascast save that money make
that money sponsors we're gonna get some
of that anyway create a list of the
services you're subscribed to and circle
the ones that you don't use obviously if
you're not using them you don't need
them yeah keep the subscriptions you use
and get the value of them from like
cancel the ones that the services that
you rarely use some of these as an
example there's apps
you know certain certain like what are
some of the things that
cancel man i was um i think paramount
plus that i use for like just one
streaming services streaming services i
had uh i think it was something a news
thing or it's like a buck there's a
bunch of random stuff it's always
something where it's like the first
month is free yeah and they're gonna hit
you for 9.99 after that and you forget
to cancel yeah
review that you know what else
gym memberships oh my god this isn't a
subscription but it is a subscription
because you gotta pay every single month
go outside you might just want to go
outside now there's gonna be people
saying we can't go outside so let's not
offend anybody but maybe that's yeah
yeah you can't go to the gym maybe i
don't know maybe a gym maybe you gotta
cancel your gym or maybe if you're using
the gym don't cancel that phone plans
those are things you could also do you
can you know renegotiate your phone
plans not saying cancel your phone but
you can renegotiate that
but here's one thing number seven that
can definitely be eliminated i think
these days with your paramount plus
keeping in mind number seven
eliminate cable cut the cord the average
american household spends 109 months
on cable 109 bucks the average american
if you pay the average amount for cable
tv you would save
hundred dollars a year by cutting the
cord yeah so with 109 extra bucks david
that might be a couple extra food orders
that you could do maybe that's a couple
extra chipotle bowls that you could
afford at that point and you can also
afford probably some you know hbo max
hulu plus netflix all for that same
price cut the court anyway that's that
those are the seven things that you can
do
each month to cut your monthly bills
okay thoughts i love
yeah cut the cord cut the cord when was
the last time you you actually watched
cable tv sports i can find online i
haven't
i used to be a big fan of tv yeah i like
tv i haven't who is watched tv i haven't
turned on my tv i haven't had a tv it's
it's i have it in my apartment i haven't
plugged it in two years going on two
years really yeah i i mean i love
youtube these days yeah shout out to
youtube i watched the valuetainment on
youtube yeah yeah yeah
uh and then everything else is on hulu
netflix not gonna lie i during the nba
playoffs i used somebody's uh
subscription to log in uh
don't hurt me espn i might have used
somebody's subscription and watched i
may or may not have i may or may not
have used somebody's login and password
to uh save a couple of shekels no big
deal
anyway uh cut the cord anyway i hope you
appreciated that
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken